this song's great i'm super into it
uh hello everyone i think we're live i
think that i've done the thing
successfully i never really know
you know it's a problem let me check it
looks like it's okay it looks like we've
done it
maybe yes okay
um i managed to time my lunch break
today so that i could actually watch a
state of play live which doesn't happen
very often
so we are going to be uh watching this
whole thing i know that it features a
ratchet and plank and from what i can
tell to other indie games
otherwise don't know very much obviously
you know we'd love to see
silent hill uh but i'm not going into
this one expecting that
i don't think that's realistic um
but i am very excited about ratchet and
clank so hyped to see more of that even
though i realized i'm not actually going
to be able to play it when it comes out
because i'll be in australia
and i can't take my ps5 it's devastating
let's go tell me if the levels are okay
alcohol reference my god
welcome to an all new state of play
we've got more than 15 minutes of new
ratchet and clank rift apart ps5
gameplay coming right up that's good but
first
let's check in on two other exciting
games coming to playstation 4 and
playstation 5 console
interesting
it to 4546b landing was
a bit rough but i don't think they've
spotted me
hi i'm jeff audio producer at unknown
worlds
set one year after the award-winning
original subnautica below zero
plunges players into a frigid underwater
adventure in search of answers
here the native wildlife above and below
this looks pretty it might consider you
it looks nice hello everyone welcome the
previous research crew has vanished
including your sister this was sam's
necklace she never took it off
to uncover that i've actually barely
played subnautica building tools and
shots
for your survival but even that but i
know a lot of people really really love
it i really should give it a go
they say it can also be super terrifying
in a really distinct way
with the ps5 dual sense controller every
icy shock feels like it's being sent
right into your hands
cool optic feedback system allows you to
feel each adrenaline filled chase
and provides visual and audio cues as
well you're all just really cute though
moments i'm not worried about being
attacked by those words uh zodiac
killing yes i will play return
on the stream yeah what's ahead not
when you play below zero on ps5 players
will get a crystal clear experience with
up to 4k
graphics targeting 60 fps when in
performance mode what does up to 4k
chris
already own a physical or digital
version of the first subnautica on ps4
you'll be able to upgrade to the digital
ps5 version at no
additional cost we hope you're as
excited as we are to dive into the world
of subnautica below zero i feel like i
should
on ps5 and ps4 i feel like i should do
it
i also have this two week period where
i'm oh interesting
well that's interesting i did not know
that this was a thing that was happening
my god is this game gonna just get even
bigger so among us is coming to
playstation is what we take from this
damn um yeah i have this two-week period
which i realized he was ratchet and
there was a click
look at him
he's so cute okay i could get back to
what i was trying to say
at this two-week period where i have to
be in a hotel in australia like you
literally have gods you can't leave
later this year thankfully we got mass
effect and i guess step nautical coming
out
around that same time next up insomniac
games will lead us on a tour of this
june's ps5 action adventure
so i'm really interested in this game i
say every time for like tech reasons
not only is it beautiful um the literal
rifts i've always been very interested
in i don't know that they work exactly
how
i originally was hoping they would
wow also very interested to learn more
about her as a character
she seems cool
[Music]
but i feel like ratchet and plank games
have always been really fun
creative exciting um even if they are
kids games i think they're awesome
they're super fun
i'm marcus smith creative director of
ratchet g'day marcus how's it going
brand new hey everybody clank adventure
wait is it jennifer hale what's up for
the playstation
oh you're talking about mass effect
whether you've played every game since
ratchet and clank's debut or you're
brand new to the series i've not played
every game
i have played a lot of that you won't
want to miss let's get into it
if this is how gameplay looks i'm just
gonna start yelling at insomnia
this is a cinematic what is this place
my god the lighting
where are you clank maybe someone around
here has seen are you serious
have any of you seen a little grey robot
anywhere green eyes
red antenna very charming but the amount
that's going on here you know
ratchet has been separated from this
friend and partner clank
and is now in a new dimension and a
mysterious urban sprawl
called nefarious city it's beautiful and
very busy
my gosh the depth of the world is insane
that's the thing
it's um they've always again had really
good worlds too all these
vary on rails in a lot of cases it seems
like this one is expanding on that a
little bit but every time i see this
game i'm just like so amazed by it
technically
obviously insomniac you know they know
what they're doing miles morales is also
very pretty but also pretty buggy
actually
in my experience ratchet quickly finds
out that in this dimension
dr nefarious is a much more capable
villain
damn dude is this gonna be like the
whole thing surely not surely this isn't
a little sandbox
i don't buy it that's too good
does that mean there are two nefariouses
now
yeah the frame rate isn't looking a
little bit off but that could be the
stream
more beautiful than ever cities are full
of life with traffic and civilians
milling about
everywhere i don't feel like that's the
game full of the unexpected
characters in this new dimension are not
always the same as they were in ratchet
and clank's dimension
ratchet comes across miss zircon the
weapon vendor in rift apart wait a
second
it looks so good
is there a problem with my audio i've
only had one person say that i don't
know
it seems okay it seems like it's the
fine
will not last the resistance
very star wars oh
apology sugar ms zerkon is still new to
all of this espionage
this is very cute
flank has been taken by a mysterious new
lombax
longbacks
[Music]
clank really can't free himself at all
i need to go after that ship how can i
get off planet
it's a test only royal starships are
allowed to leave
anything else
yeah there are even frame rate drops in
the cinematics so my thing my thinking
is
it's the stream that's dropping and not
on my end i would say on the broadcast
got it oh and nice work secret agent
zircon
but i guess we'll see this is so
exciting
club nefarious shouldn't be hard this is
very impressive
this is the thing that i generally get
hyped about when it comes to video games
and like some people tell me not to
because it's like irresponsible if i get
hyped i'm not gonna not share my
excitement
like that's so silly i'm not gonna do
that i'm not trying to get other people
hyped
never i'm just sharing my excitement and
i'm not gonna like tailor that back
just because of youtube uh excitement is
fun but i
tech is always what gets me um obviously
i get excited about video games
narratively
in a bunch of ways but you know someone
who walks in the industry and
uh just wants to see it grow more
you know i was very excited about the
potential for the industry
this [ __ ] just makes me like damn look
how pretty you are
because right now it would be too
expensive to develop a game with like a
full bustling city
like it's possible but it's too
expensive
this is pretty bustling all things
considered obviously the style
not being super photo realistic it's not
like they haven't put a lot of effort
into them
he learns a couple of lighting um
basically it's just like we'll get to a
point where we can do that where we can
have
like a full rendered new york city and
you could go in the buildings that would
be possible
just very far away when it gets cheaper
to do
like there's so many things in video
games that we haven't had yet
but with ratchet it's mostly just damn
it's pretty
i do not think we're going to get an
elden ring update ismail i'm sorry now
let's jump into combat
nefarious day spa if you can distract
these troopers
i'll hack the fairies as propaganda
blimp and give this city a message it'll
never forget
looks easy enough
do you think furries feel represented by
ratchet
probably not right maybe i don't know
i'm not sure how that works because he's
not a furry he's just
actually a long box i'm not sure dashing
allows you
these are the questions that keep me up
at strategic advantages enemies can't
hit what doesn't moment
yeah official it definitely depends on
the graphics which is really just a
fidelity really
i don't know if among us is going to be
free use the rift
another new traversal mechanic to
instantly pull yourself across
battlefields to escape or flank enemies
calm i don't think we get anything else
from the stream they could drop
something
very exciting at the end i would blood
one two i would take that chris
feedback to allow players to really feel
them but i don't think
we will get anything other than with the
burst pistol the two games we already
got and
check the trigger partway to peck out
accurately placed
single shots but pulling the trigger
fully oh that's nice which is a rapid
fire spread
that's cool i really like the jewels in
either case players will
feel each shot burst from the weapon and
connect with enemy
with the enforcer players can pull the
trigger down halfway to fire a single
barrel
reducing time between reloads or pull
the trigger fully it's a really small
way to do that i'm i'm
excited to see how that feels it might
feel really weird but haptics the player
will
feel the power of their shots through
their hands the teleport thing is just
so
neat it's so cool like that animation is
so cool the way it just pulls
let's move ahead it's awesome
also very in all this love a wall run
who doesn't as ratchet attempts to
follow rivet and clank
he encounters a nefarious juggernaut
where did you even come from
this thing that they're doing this
ability or whatever is i don't know what
it is that's making
ratchet okay drag behind himself
thanks to the power trip okay so this is
near instantly teleport players to
completely different locations is so
cool
some small arena being loaded but the
entire level
from a different planet it's so cool
that's so fast it's just the loading is
just in that little
that little tiny bit where you see the
fragments which they let's jump over and
see what made makes sense
[Music]
as you may have guessed rivet is a brand
new playable character in the series
this is also beautiful where are you
taking me
i was going to take you to my hideout
but first
i got a restaurant why are you still in
the closet factory why is that happening
see what's he done to deserve this
i'm supposed to play as her i don't
consent to this i'm gonna just take
clank back
rude um there is kind of an e3 this year
but i wouldn't expect it to be like
that dimension and actually classic
planets from past ipods i definitely
have not watched this already
what do you mean i'm acting like i
watched it already definitely haven't
um
yeah there is kind of an e3 this year
but not really it's like it's just going
to be two months of
conferences spread out from my own audio
we've been able to create alien planets
with an immersive density like never
before
this is insane let's check it out you're
right that it is an immersive density
all the reviews are going to say that
back to ms zircon the weapons vendor
oh she's everywhere this wasn't what was
in my account last time
oh that is because i added our
mutual friend on nefarious city
okay so wait now she can also that's a
small way to do that explosive
new arsenal as well as a few returning
classes an issue that i had with a
recent video game where you play as two
separate characters
who are technically against each other
was uh halfway through swapping to
resetting all of your inventory and all
of your upgrades i found to be kind of
annoying and
the problem that i had with the reviews
for that was that you weren't allowed to
say that
sprinkler
and are ready to be trimmed down
that's cool
these effects man
in addition to rift tethering and
dimensional shifts there are also many
pocket dimensions
scattered throughout the game and the
last speedle runs into that rift
thingy interesting you must have a rift
tether in your glove
too what does it do
all right smarty bot what is this place
i
um a dimensional pocket ryan
death lips got delayed devastating
i'm so excited about that game but you
know that's all the time you need
make it good this is cool it's very
pretty
it's like almost like a completely
different environment inside of an
emerald wandered in through the rift
somehow
there is the speedl
this music makes me think of crash
hitting its nest might get its attention
and is also very [ __ ] rude
all right okay
you've got a lot of gameplay variety in
this small chunk of time i think
i wonder how long this game's gonna be i
don't remember if they've said
i just feel like ratchet clank obviously
he's not played paternal yet very
excited too
is is a very good showcase for um
yeah ps5 what that ssd can do
riding speedls is one way of traversing
sargasso's acid swamps
and to do so quickly excuse me just look
very hot
looks like a good time i got it i got it
see sometimes i don't crash
it's so busy you know we didn't follow
that
across dementia yes they did say that
there would be 15 minutes of
ratchet so that's probably
[Laughter]
people on the playstation chat are just
yelling about like previous gameplay
rebranded games just like skip next game
please did you not did you not look into
what it was going to be about now
also trapped in rivets i think we have
this weird thing where people have
certain
the shatter bomb is a frag type grenade
that deals a lot of damage to your foes
cool with haptic feedback each explosion
beautiful
absolutely beautiful oh i like that
they're using happy feedback for that
too that's so pretty
um people keep getting upset when
conferences
aren't what they want they'll be like it
was it was trash like sony lost that a
playstation lost that or xbox lost that
uh but they're not reading what they are
ahead of time
you can't expect any press conference
every day of the week
they are telling you generally what what
to expect in them
that's cool that's like some quake [ __ ]
damn the particles man
it's beautiful it's just so beautiful
this is just a small taste of some of
the early gameplay in rift apart
but there is so much more we have open
areas to explore
dimensional clank puzzles yeah i wonder
how big they are oh that's cool
dimensional clank puzzles all right
arena challenges
aerial combat this looks neat this
game's gonna be so much fun
i wonder if there's a way i can get a
ps5 in australia just like borrow it off
someone just to play the game
pocket dimensions to it because
otherwise i gotta wait till i come home
and all the cool stuff's gonna be
spoiled
to obtain and use in the first ever
ratchet and clank photo mode
nice ah they did such a good job with
the
the photo mode and um always important
us ability to place lights
apart will offer a slew of accessibility
options awesome
we'll reveal more about this soon that's
experience very important
to reveal ahead of time so people with
certain disabilities
know if they can even play game it's so
sucky that sometimes they have to buy it
and then
find out within an hour that they can't
play it because not enough companies
release their accessibility options
ahead of time it's something that um i
think is very important and
people seem to be
thank you for watching thank you for
having me in the omniverse
i can't wait it looks great that's our
show
we explored the depths of an alien ocean
gotta first look at among us on
playstation
and zipped across space and time in
ratchet and clank rift
i don't know what else they would have
shown of among us it's the interesting
thing it's like yup that's that's pretty
much the game thanks for watching except
that you're right
thank you appreciate you thanks very
much anything else probably not
right
what a wonderful surprise hey big guy
what do you want nefarious we're going
to a dimension
where i always win
tomiak are just so good they're just so
good
oh the only reason i can't take my
playstation 5 back home is because it's
too big i won't be able to fit it
let's go for a ride wait i have to find
my friend
emperor nefarious you have returned
[Music]
well doug that was not supposed to be
any god of war in this it was supposed
to be
two andes and ratchet flank that is what
they said ahead of time
that's what we got we may lose every
dimension
oh my
i think this game is gonna be so much
fun
and i'm gonna spend the whole time just
looking at lighting
and like water being like damn how they
do that though
it's very pretty
i imagine that's actually it now i would
think probably
um i'm not taking a ps4 no i will be
taking an xbox series s because it's so
small
and uh a razer gaming laptop which is
mostly what i'm gonna be using so it
should work out okay
can't do any like remote play stuff
because it won't work very well in a
hotel room
um that was fun it was fun it was pretty
much exactly what i would have expected
thank you all for joining me live
uh it's cool to be able to get to do one
of these i can't always do it because
it doesn't work in in the workday so
often i have to do it afterwards um but
i managed to
make it work today so yeah thanks for
joining me
i completely agree unique technique
except people that don't give colorful
colorful kids games a chance of missing
out on fun experiences some of them are
so good like the um
uh what is it called
the game that comes with the ps5
playroom
is um looks really childish but it's so
cool
uh i can't do remote play in australia
because my internet connection is not
gonna be fast enough in my hotel room
kevin
it's not gonna work
um well strongly disagree with that one
godspeed
but uh yeah thank you all for joining me
super fun this was very fun
um hopefully doing play watch listen
while i'm away i don't know yet i'll
keep everyone updated i don't know if
the internet will be fast enough to do
the show
we'll see but yeah i gotta go thank you
all for joining me